attention captive test subjects the
Institute for mad science has sent to me
my first experiment to inflict on you
okay now let's do it right so I can get
on to the real mad scientist stuff like
pulling the heads off monkeys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to the latest
episode of 13 o'clock hope everyone is
doing well today
nobody here doing that so she have a
show yes well actually the first thing I
would like to do like to give a shout
out to end of days radio Michael Deacon
and I was live on end of days on this
past Saturday night which was the 15th
they should post that up and yeah they
they usually post up the the archived
shows in today's rodeo yeah I wasn't on
it that night I've been on it before
yeah it's just Jenny on our own promoter
new book yeah it's a good show so yeah
and then you got another one this week
coming up country yeah I'm also um
tomorrow I'll be taping a an interview
with Jim Harold yeah I believe it's
gonna be his ghost insight show yes
several it's got a bunch of shows he's
got several radio show so yeah I'm gonna
be on that promoting my new book which
as I said last week it's called the
unseen hand a new exploration of
poltergeist phenomena yeah and it's now
out in print ebook and audiobook right
available on Amazon so you know if
you're into poltergeist stuff and want
to read about pretty much every
poltergeist case I could find from the
past
it's a since the first century right if
you're into that kind of thing then pick
up a copy and if you like it then give
me a review because that really does
help yeah so what's uh what's on the
show today
Oh we'll wait a minute first project
Entertainment Network I always have to
say about that
yeah um so you know shout out to them
like we usually do and so the topic
today is Mad Science okay
NASA is not not weird science now well
here's the thing I didn't want to call
it weird science right and and that's
the thing like the song you'd have to
play at the yes
and and I know that that would have been
the most obvious one but that wasn't the
one I went I went with the second most
are the second most obvious song up rare
times now when I first now I'm gonna
want to do like kind of a mad science
kind of show for a while I wanted to
stick with cases that maybe weren't as
well-known as some of the kind of bigger
ones I also didn't want to go full-on
like war atrocities like you know
yeah human human experimental and all
that kind of stuff can I stamp knees
yeah I thought that North Koreans are
actually doing that too yeah like all
the vivisection and like poisoning twins
and all that kind of [ __ ]
it's like you know I was like that might
be too much of a bummer not like we
haven't done bomber shows in the past
but right now I thought it would be but
not not that these cases are like super
fun or anything like that but I just
these were the ones that I thought were
we're kind of interesting I'm sort of
weird and the thing about these cases
too is that other than the Freud one
which I don't think was very um useful
at all these other ones as kind of
strange and unethical as they were they
actually maybe did provide some useful
information going forward so it's just
kind of you know the way that the
information was obtained was perhaps not
so not so pleasant and so the first one
we're gonna talk about is dr. Harry
Harlow and I don't know if a lot of
people I mean his name is not super
common but probably most people have
heard of his monkey studies because
they're actually quite famous now Harry
Harlow was a psychologist and initially
he started out studying cognition and
memory and stuff like that and he used
you know rhesus monkeys rhesus macaques
as you know a lot of people at their
well they still do as far as I know and
since he was experimenting using the
baby rhesus macaque so he in 1932 he
established a breeding colony of them
now he kind of would
take them out like the ones he was going
to use the experiments he would take
them away from their mothers when they
were babies and he would raise them in
nursery settings like their you know he
would train like his students and
undergraduates and stuff that you know
how to care for them and stuff like that
but he started to notice that the
monkeys that were taken away from their
mothers were kind of messed up like the
you know they they were kind of socially
they were very clingy like he noticed
that they had little cloth diapers and
they would like hang on to them like
they were like security blankets yeah
he also noticed that they displayed a
lot of fear and aggression and that they
didn't socialize well with the other
monkeys not you know not the same way
okay that the monkeys that were raised
by their mothers dead so then he kind of
got interested in the infant maternal
bond now it should be noted that prior
to this time this was in the 1930s that
he was doing west of his studies prior
to this time it was largely accepted in
this in the field of psychology that the
only reason that children bonded with
their mothers was because that was where
they got food from okay so they didn't
think you know largely they didn't think
that there was any other type of bonding
happening between a mother in the kid
they thought it was just because that's
where milk comes from and so this is why
I think you know modern people look back
at sort of the the way they treated
children you know in the end of the you
know 19th century early 20th century
like the orphanages and stuff like that
where they didn't think it was
detrimental to children to not be to not
have any affection displayed toward them
or be picked an executive yeah pretty
much
you know they didn't think that was
harmful right and they thought that if
you did do it then it was harmful
because it was spoiling that right so
they kind of encouraged parents to like
oh don't pick your kids up don't show
them any affection don't do anything
like that so that was kind of not the
consensus obviously but because there
were some psychologists that disagreed
with that and then
to 30s but you know that was kind of the
the majority kind of had that view
however so many psychos during that and
that's what I was gonna say that's what
I was thinking too maybe that's why
people were so messed up like back then
because spoiler alert that is actually
very very harmful the children to treat
them that way and um and it actually was
largely because of this guise of dr.
Harlow's work that this was figured out
now the first thing he did was kind of a
maternal experiment because he wanted to
show that there were other things going
on with the bonding than just food so
what he would do was he would take these
baby monkeys he built a wire mother and
he built a cloth mother and now he said
that the baby monkeys they you know they
recognized these you know fake surrogate
mothers you know and they would prefer
the one that was assigned to them but
all of before over all other ones now he
wanted to see he's like okay he took the
wire mother and put a bottle on it so
they could be nursed off of and then you
know he would do it both ways he would
have the wire mother with with the thing
and then the cloth mother didn't have
milk or he would take her the cloth
mother had milk and then the wire mother
didn't have milk now he said even when
the wire mother had the bottle attached
yeah the monkeys would go over and drink
from that but then they would go right
back to the cloth mother and hug it
right so photographs of that yeah yeah
there are photographs that little happy
face kind of thing on the top of those
yeah yeah it's it yeah it was yeah it
was like a pretty famous experiment yes
so from that he said okay well obviously
they're getting something else you know
from these surrogates other than just
milk because you know they didn't love
the wire mother's at all they just went
over there to get milk and then they
went back and cuddled on the cloth one
and he said it was interesting too
because they used the the cloth mother
almost like it as a base of exploration
Brooke you know like they would go back
to the cloth mother if something scary
was like introduced into the cage or
something like that so they used it for
free reassurance
protection and stuff like that now this
is not to say that these baby monkeys
that were raised by the surrogate
mothers we're still kinda messed up they
weren't you know because they didn't
really get to interact with any other
baby monkeys and they didn't get to
interact with a real mother they turned
out better than later ones okay but but
you know they they were still had some
problems although most of them were able
to be rehabilitated like when they got a
little bit older like he would
reintroduce them back into you know and
let them hang out with like other little
monkeys their age and then they would
usually be alright he's like they were
usually still kind of introverted and
sometimes aggressive or something like
that but not too bad but then he kind of
got he kind of got interested in what if
these baby monkeys were completely
deprived of any interaction whatsoever
not even a fake mother yeah and you know
so and like I said valuable information
but it almost seemed sick why did you
have to go to that next level man monkey
baby monkey yeah how could you do that I
don't know so he built this box and
here's another thing Harlow evidently he
had some he was kind of an
anti-establishment kind of like I don't
like the psychological establishment
kind of guy and he didn't like kind of
the euphemisms well I guess because he
had used this um you know love
deprivation kind of experimentation and
he called it love he's like in the set
in the psychology field at the time they
called it attachment and he thought that
was kind of [ __ ] and he's like
really should call things what they are
and you know he had this one thing that
he built that was like a like a forced
mating kind of contraption and he called
it the rape wreck what you know so he
kind of called things what they were so
what he did was he built this
technically it was a sensory deprivation
kind of box and he called it the pit of
despair
like he named it that it wasn't somebody
else named it that he noted that and
this was you know basically oh-ho-ho
go back to this break machine what are
you talking you know it's weird because
I don't know how many he was rated
Amalfi's on it he wasn't writing funky
he was forcing them to mate with each
other what was the effects of that I
don't know it wasn't it wasn't mentioned
in that no not really I know it's like
you can't really say rape rack and then
not really know expound on yeah but yeah
oh yeah he's a dick
yeah and like I said you know I
appreciate that he actually you know
came to this psychological you know
establishment it was like no you have to
love your kids and like pick them up and
like show them affection or stuff like
that otherwise they turn out [ __ ] up
well what's the pit of despair of the
pit of despair he built and this was in
the 50s so he had been doing quite a lot
of experimentation through the 30s and
40s but what he would do he had partial
isolation where he would have you know a
cage where the baby monkeys could see
other baby monkeys but couldn't touch
him or couldn't do anything like that
and then he had some that were in the
pit of despair that were these total
isolation chambers was it dark in there
or light in there you know um I don't
think it really said they looked like
I mean fern if there's a couple photos
of him like on the internet I'll put him
in the out put it in the YouTube video
it looked like it would have been dark
in there okay but they couldn't hear any
other monkeys they couldn't see them
they couldn't touch them they couldn't
smell them they got anything like that
and sometimes he had different time
periods they could leave them in there
like so he would leave them alone for 3
months 6 months a year two years yeah
and he would leave you know like
obviously fed them and stuff like that
but the you know the the people that fed
them weren't allowed to interact with
them or anything like that and he left
them in there total social deprivation
yeah that's true it is yeah the sad
thing is that I mean none of the monkeys
died while they were in isolation but
you know obviously the
pending on how long they stayed in now
one that had been in there for three
months when they let him out he wouldn't
eat and he starved to death look you
know because he was so messed up and
that was that was only after three
months he left some in there for like a
year yeah and he said when those monkeys
came out they acted like like they had
severe autism he's like they would
pretty much curl up in a corner they
stared at nothing they would hug
themselves and just rock back and forth
things like that they were just totally
he couldn't fix him now some of them
were able to be rehabilitated a little
bit right like if they were reintroduced
back into their peer group and things
like that they were never really right
again right but some of them kind of got
over the weird that like it took a while
hmm but it's just it's sad because and
here's the thing like I said is this
important research probably but I'm
really pretty obvious that that would
screw you what do you think why do you
need to experiment but like I said it
seemed weird that like at the time that
he started like in the early 1930s it
was almost kind of like a given that no
you shouldn't like pamper your kids or
you shouldn't like hug your kids or
anything like that because it spoils
them so obviously it did need to be
experimented on because people didn't
know [ __ ] yeah so and the and the sad
thing about it it's like like I said the
guys you know research was probably felt
valuable and it probably helped a lot
and you know a mother mother infant
attachment and things like that but it
must be said the guy not an animal lover
no he did not like and he spit said that
straight out he's like I don't like
animals huh he said I don't like cats I
don't like dogs I don't he's like how
can you love a monkey I'm like but
here's the thing he's a dick the whole
point the whole point of doing
experiments on monkeys right is because
they're so similar to humans like so
yeah so I guess he must be a misanthrope
monkeys are very similar to people I
mean that's the whole point of it's
using them in experiments because their
reactions are so similar I'm not you
know I'm not like an animal rights
activist where I go out you know it's
like oh you can't wear fur you know I've
actually caught it you know oh yeah
every animal I kill I ate it yeah it
don't waste animals and here's the thing
hi animals like monkeys monkeys aren't
really prey animals you know you know
yeah my point of view you know deer and
birds you know you eat those yeah but
there's no I mean I don't see any point
in and I'm not an appointment yeah doing
what he's doing yeah and now I mean it
should be said to that that it was
probably largely his work that led to
kind of the animal liberation movement
and Brook more attention being drawn to
how animals were treated sure animals
can suffer in captivity sure I am sure
it's obvious again and like I said I
don't I don't necessarily have a problem
with some types of animal
experimentation depending on what it is
right there but there's a fine line and
there's a fine line between you know are
you making these animals suffer
needlessly
yeah and hiss get in this case I would
say yes yes why would you take a poor
little baby monkey and the increase
attacks are adorable
especially the babies are adorable they
look like little fuzzy human baby and
totally ruin this little animals like um
yeah I mean they messed them up forever
pretty much they were never right again
really that's disgusting
yeah it's awful but you know like I said
this is some mad science trap so okay so
well all right the next thing I want to
talk about since that was that was a
little bit of a bummer why this was kind
of a bummer to but okay next thing I
wanna talk about is the Hoffa leg a
hospital experiment now after World War
2 and particularly after the Nuremberg
trials there was a lot of interest in
the psychological field about how how
the Germans had gone along with Nazi
atrocities so they were interested in
studies of how people reacted to
Authority how easy it was to get people
to compromise their principles and
things of that nature now probably the
most
famous experiment in that line was the
Milgram experiment where you know most
people know Stanley Milgram and he did
it and the simulator proves this no that
was the Stanford experiment the Milgram
experiment was when they got people that
he ostensibly said it's ostensibly about
the study was about punishment on
learning oh yeah yes so you shot he so
he would yeah he would shock people
quote-unquote the learners if they got
something wrong yeah and it was alarming
how many of the people I mean obviously
the people weren't really being shocked
they've just told the the subjects that
they were shocking them it was alarming
how many of the people would shock these
people what they thought was to their
death yeah to a lethal dose just because
someone in a lab coat told them to yeah
so um you know and there was also kind
of this wasn't like you know this wasn't
like a scientifically like a lab
experiment but one kind of social
experiment that a teacher did was the
third wave where he did it with his high
school class because he wanted to see
how easily his students could be sucked
into fascism because he was he was doing
a chapter on Nazi Germany and he wanted
to demonstrate to them how easy it would
have been to get them to go along with
all this kind of stuff and that pretty
much only took about five days before
they were all they were all in man so
you know a little alarming he's like I
just um it's for a good cause
fascism is always for a good cause
that's what they tell us a little bit
yeah and it's like so it is like kind of
alarming how easy it is to get people to
do things you know even psychologically
normal people to get things to do that
they wouldn't normally do probably
so the huffing hospital experiment was
kind of similar it was a kind of a study
of authority and what and how people
would kind of just do whatever if
somebody in authority told them to and
this happened actually in the 60s 1966
now he wanted to do like a field
experiment now the first thing he did it
was between doctors and nurses so he
took surveys of a bunch of nurses and a
bunch of nursing students and he said
now if a doctor that you didn't know
asked you to do XYZ that you
wasn't right would you do it now
overwhelmingly like 99% of them said of
course not of course they're not gonna
listen to some doctor that tells them to
do something that they know isn't right
okay well then he's like all right so he
did the actual experiment what he did
was he had an accomplice call a hospital
and say he was a doctor named dr. Smith
and he told a whole bunch of nurses give
the patients 20 milligrams of this
fictitious drug the drug was called
Astro 10 now prior to this they had
actually had a bottle made that said a
certain and you know had a label on it
everything now the label said maximum
dose 10 milligrams right now nurses in
pretty much every Hospital I'm sure in
the 60s and I'm sure nowadays are told
many things and one of them is like
don't take you know don't take
instructions from a doctor you don't
know who it is right you know and don't
administer things without the proper
paperwork and all this other kind of
stuff so this doctor calls these all
these nurses says I'm dr. Smith I don't
have the paperwork to have this drug
administered but I'll do it when I get
there
administer 20 milligrams of this
fictitious drug called a certain to
these particular patients all but one of
them did it hmm all but one and you know
the one that did it was just like nah
that's not right I don't have the
paperwork and I don't and this says ten
milligrams and he said twenty I don't
know who this guy is and stuff like that
right and you know so so he or she they
didn't specify but he or she would not
do it but the other ones all did Wow
because it was an authority figure tell
me because it was an authority figure
telling them to do it right and even the
ones that had the ones that had done it
had actually been some of the people in
the survey before hand that had said
they would never do so she's right
and like I said this at the outcome was
pretty much the same as the now I think
in the Milgram experiment
those weren't doctors they were
scientists you know you know same diff
but they had people said you know Oh
it'll be fine just keep shocking the
people and you never even have window
dude another screamin and stuff like
that I saw a movie about that an old
movie from seventies yeah and they're
here the guy in the other room no please
no more no more the other guy the white
coachman no go ahead you can shock him
as part of the experiment he's are you
sure yeah that might kill him it's on
you yeah okay now but some think more
people in the Milgram experiment did say
no right like they left right because
that's the thing it and that's the thing
I don't understand like I don't like I
don't want to say that that would never
happen but I mean I'm a very like I said
it I think I mentioned this on our show
about cults where I'm just kind of like
when somebody tells me to do something
I'm just like I don't I don't want to do
that yeah it doesn't work that way in
cults and yeah political type
organizations people will do what
they're told if they believe what
they're doing is morally the correct
thing yeah you just have to set up a
long history with a person of a certain
belief structure it really when you have
to set that up first to prime them yeah
to get them to do it well in a lot of
ways you know if you do it kind of
slowly and like I said I think this kind
of happened in Nazi Germany as well it
kind of just ramped up in notches and
just Ratchet it up right it wasn't like
they just came out we're like let's kill
all the Jews right you know it was kind
of like a slow progression up to that
place they just start off with anger
towards them yeah and then eventually
one day we'll get them yeah we're gonna
make them pay and eventually is we're
making them pay right now that's
eventually but don't tell anybody
yeah yeah it's not just politics though
religions do the same thing well they do
yeah yeah it's like I said it's like the
fabled frog in boiling water it's just
like just little steps at a time and
suddenly you're committing war
atrocities and you have no idea
you got that yeah it's always like
nietzsche said you know he who chases
dragons too long becomes a dragon
himself yeah are like gazing into yes
because the best way to be the best way
to the fascism of the future is
anti-fascism if you can take anything to
extremes well yeah that for sure
anything can be taken to extremes you
kind of see that now some of the stuff
that the political extreme extremism
going on in American politics in an
American Society yeah hey mister being
created yeah I mean you know generally
that does happen I think people kind of
become become more polarized but I
thought the centers getting bigger well
that well that's that's exactly what I
was gonna say as the center gets larger
I think the extremes get more big think
it's smaller but they get more
radicalized that that's kind of happened
throughout history ah yeah but we're
coming up to the halfway point so I'm
gonna take a break right now and when we
get back we're gonna talk a little bit
about Freud and we're also gonna talk a
little bit about a kind of a pretty sad
case of sex reassignment gone wrong oh
yeah
and yeah this was a really terrible case
I read the book about it and stuff too
yeah but we'll talk about that when we
get back and we'll be back in just a
couple minutes
once upon a time a madman poet and thief
known as John urban sick that's me
challenged himself myself to write a
story a day every day for a year by hand
some of them worked
some of them fed some of them were
spectacular then I did it again join me
every week for ink stains as I do it a
third time and I will read you some of
these stories I'll talk about the
process about creativity in general
writing and specific and maybe I can
help ignite your artistic adventures
[Music]
subculture corsets and clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm
that's subculture corsets calm make sure
you use the discount code 13 o'clock for
a 10% discount subculture corsets calm
or visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 three guys with
beards the usual gang avidians that's me
Christopher gold a New York Times
bestselling authors my name is Jim more
interviews with pop culture stars and
creators some Jonathan Mayberry and they
don't talk about politics I said they
don't talk about politics didn't you say
they don't talk about politics if
somebody else says something we should
thank you anyone three guys with beards
Tuesdays exclusively on project
entertainment network
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right and we're back talking about
mad science now this one this one's not
quite as much of a bummer because this
one's just kind of well we got the one
out of the way yeah it was a bummer for
one person but because all of those
monkeys monkeys just as much as I like
squirrels yeah oh my god you have no
idea how much he loves score let's go we
got our walk that what squirrels come
down I talk to squirrels yeah I try to
courage the squirrel see come at me bro
but they do watch me the cabana dude's
crazy
he's like the squirrel Whisperer yeah
I'm gonna start taking crackers with me
yeah you should yeah oh my god then then
every day we'll go for a walk and
they'll be jumping on your head and
stuff and I'm gonna videotape every
second of that joke without the podcast
yeah that'd be funny as hell all right
so this one was a kind of a bummer for
one person but but in a way it was kind
of like goofy for everyone else involved
no Sigmund Freud obviously very famous
person um a lot of his beliefs kind of
pseudo-scientific he had some legit
ideas in there overall man you know for
all free was a quack kind of a quasi
behind a sec he was important quack
though yeah but he was a quack like I
said some of the [ __ ] he came up with I
don't have any beef with Senna some of
it was pretty legit okay so what ended
up happening now Freud had a patient
named Emma Eckstein and he actually saw
her for three years I think she was one
of his longest longest termed early
patients now she was actually I'm not
sure if she was a psychoanalyst while
she was being treated she became one
later but she you know she was very you
know on that bandwagon and she actually
became a psychoanalyst herself later on
and was actually quite well respected
and had some you know some stuff
published that you know is still kind of
read today but she initially went to
Freud complaining about stomach problems
like digestive problems and menstruation
related depression now because this was
Freud and Freud is kind of like
everything is a sexual problem whether
it's a sexual problem or not he
basically said well you're a woman so
obviously you have to stare
because women be crazy yeah we're so
crazy and also that her hysteria was
caused by her masturbating - yeah
because evidently I mean at the time
before it was fantasizing too much she
has me I think so too because I yeah I
kind of feel like that said a lot more
about frustation for real like some of
the [ __ ] he came up with did with
yourself I was gonna do it adjourn it's
your fault it's your fault it is right
victorian-era
well yeah and and it should be said that
I mean Freud was not the only one it's
like masturbation back then was
considered to be a sign of mental
illness yeah especially all crazy yeah
especially if you did it too much well I
don't know how much too much is but
whatever I'm like so everyone on earth
is crazy then awesome pretty much people
from that area where people from that
from that era they were they were that
yeah yeah sorry how many was thinking
you know Xbox one I don't know now keep
in mind keep in mind to that I still
have four or five episodes of the new
Mystery Science Theater yeah which is
very good yeah I was like like I gave to
the Kickstarter you guys this is how
excited I was about this about this cuz
I am like the world's biggest mystery
science theater fan I love that [ __ ] and
I'm like an old school fan I started
watching it like in the early night in
the 90s 92 93 girl watch female
masturbation - well I'll get back to it
and is that go I'll go back to that in a
second but yeah but I so I was scared
like I gave him a bunch of money in the
Kickstarter but um you know I got a
shirt and I got all kind of neat stuff
but I was kind of scared I'm like oh
it's all new people and you know is it
gonna be the same and stuff it rocks
it's so funny it's like it's super
hilarious it's like it's still yeah it's
all new people but it still has the same
kind of charm and they you know they
they didn't change a lot you know it's
still kind of the same I wasn't a huge
fan of the originals I mean how long I
thought this kind of play yeah that kind
of humor really
my thing but this is new and I think the
humor welven yeah well I think they went
oh they have musical humor la jokin yeah
break I think a lot of the references
aren't quite as obscure just don't want
it [ __ ] was you have to be like super
super dorky to get a lot of that stuff
yeah which I know pal that's my level
well I like him to do that like Dave
Chappelle I kind of like low growl and I
oh that's why I always liked Mystery
Science Theater because they kind of had
something for everybody right but so
anyway yet excessive masturbation is we
were talking about yeah okay so this was
this woman's problem evidently yeah now
it so happens that at the time Freud was
buddy-buddy with a guy named Wilhelm
Fleiss it was actually an ear nose and
throat specialist now much like Freud
thought everything was sex problems
Fleiss thought everything was nose
problems and also sex problems and so he
kind of combined those two things
because noses and [ __ ] go so nicely
together and this kind of theory that
was called I think it was called nasal
reflux neurosis yeah that's what it was
called yeah and where it was some kind
of thing where I'm not sure if he
thought he kind of thought that there
was some kind of relationship between
your nose and your genitalia so almost
like so I'm not sure if he went the
whole way of like saying well if you
pick your nose it's just kind of like
you know people from the 1800 pervs
they really remember man they're weird
it's like they talk about people
perverted nowadays I'm like no we didn't
have nothing on those people I think
because they were so repressed this I
just gotta find a warmth yeah they were
warm they had to better work yeah about
it in a way I like it better now like
now that the Internet's there and it's
like you know people have like weird
fetishes but you can find other people
online that have weird fetishes and [ __ ]
if you're not hurtin anybody I'll give a
crap I think I think weird fetishes
drove them crazy back then yeah because
when the repression would cause more
fetishes weirder fetishes yeah because
of the guilt and because you didn't know
anyone else she thought you were the
only one and I thought you were a weirdo
and stuff like that I end up with a
bunch of Albert Finnish type
that's what I mean it's like I kind of
think that contributed to maybe this
kind of perverted serial killer type
thing because I don't know if you see
that as much as you used to like it was
bad in the 70s and 80s I remember yeah
but I think it's gotten better thinking
Internet it's taking a lot of pressure
off those guys yeah because if you're a
weirdo you can find like if you have
those kind of proclivities you can find
other people online kind of sympathize
so you don't feel so isolated I said I
think plus I think social media is kind
of intimated the social isolation needs
to happen right a pre-internet era and
we were like from an age of darkness
before there wasn't it I now I remember
when there was no way it's like Dave
Chappelle said you didn't know who was
calling you until you answer define you
always had to answer it might have been
important so so yeah so this poor woman
MX scene they thought that her problem
stemmed something to do with her sexual
maturation it had something to do with
her nose right yeah so Freud recommended
that she undergo this kind of surgery
that this Fleiss person was doing where
they would basically cauterize the
inside of your nose like you do you take
away your smell yeah like I guess to
make you stop jerking it I don't know I
don't take away most your sense of taste
- well yeah that's that's what food
tastes like [ __ ] back then anyway yeah
so it was probably you know probably you
wouldn't yeah it might have been better
you know so so basically they cauterized
that her nose because he had evidently
he had done some of these types of
surgeries before and deemed them
successful now I don't think it was
successful because their noses ricotta
eyes die think they were deemed
successful because they were given
cocaine afterward what's you know
that'll cheer you right up right so I
think that's what was causing the
success from the nasal cauterization
just a theory yeah all these guys from
this era were all quacks I don't know
why they why they're quoted probably had
you know 10% likes there was some
nuggets not good [ __ ] yeah like I
don't know the exact percentage but you
know so evidently the surgery did not go
as planned
I think yome was closer to the truth
actually I probably yeah so this poor
woman and he ended up almost being
involved in spiritualism and stopped and
didn't yo sort of yeah we kind of went
on there spiritualism or what was it
some kind of you started believe the
supernatural stuff like New Age you kind
of said yeah but I don't remember what
it was exactly I was gonna say we should
do a show on call you know do you think
about that that would be a fascinating
show Emma Eckstein her surgery did not
go as planned her nose started bleeding
all the time and stuff like that she
went back to see about it and turns out
just like on pretty much every other
episode of monsters inside me
the doctor had actually left about a
half meter of gauze up her nose yeah and
so they pulled it all out and she
evidently like snorted out like all this
puss and like bone and all this other
stuff and she was permanently disfigured
yeah well center of her head collapsed
and pretty much yeah yeah her face
pretty much caved in all because they
thought that she was masturbating too
much and for some reason then that's a
joke oh yeah oh drive you crazy yeah
so I don't know how those things became
associated I guess they weren't but yeah
so that was that sad story and obviously
the nasal whatever the nasal sex theory
I'm discredited obviously although I'm
sure there's probably some nose
fetishists out there somewhere because
you know see Internet and it's rule 34
pretty much everything everything has
porn of us I'm sure there's nose born so
uh yeah I know what's next okay so the
last case I want to talk about and I
actually read a book about this kid he
was a kid at the time and this was kind
okay this is kind of a pretty sad case
back in the 60s there was a doctor named
John money
and I don't want to [ __ ] on the guy too
much because he actually he's actually a
very well-respected psychologist he did
a great deal of work in helping patients
like intersex patients what they would
have called hermaphrodites back in the
day who were born with ambiguous
genitalia or you know had both sets of
genitalia or neither set of genitalia or
were you know had chromosomal
abnormalities that caused them to be
their gender to be ambiguous yes then
and that's a thing - that's a thing and
that's more common than people thought
it is very common and I was surprised at
how common it was it is very common for
babies to be born with ambiguous gender
so where they can't tell one the other I
looked back to my high school days and
some people come to mind the other but
they were like that yeah and also like I
said chromosomal disorders like X X Y
and things like that are also very
common he actually was it was quite well
known for you know for working with
these types of patients and you know
kind of helping normalizer take away the
stigma attached to them and helping them
out with various surgeries and stuff
like that now unfortunately one case
that really kind of tarnished his
reputation and it's and it's really kind
of probably the thing that he's best
known for nowadays I mean he died in the
80s but um that he's best known for
nowadays was this really and and this is
very very very questionably the ethics
of this were very very questionable in
1965 there were a pair of twin boys born
Bruce and Brian
Reimer now when the boys were seven or
eight months old they were having
problems urinating yeah so and they were
diagnosed with Phi Moses you know which
is where your foreskin doesn't retract
all the way back and whatnot so doctors
recommended is gonna say something funny
do what were you gonna say on that I it
slipped away okay it's funny if you
don't have it I'm sure
but they I mean these were babies still
right so their doctor recommended that
they be circumcised so they were not
circumcised for religious reasons they
were not I mean nowadays it seems like a
lot of babies are circumcised just cuz
which I don't know why they do that but
make it look pretty I guess but so these
babies were not were circumcised later
because of a medical issue
unfortunately Bruce was the first one to
be circumcised now for some reason I
don't know why but they decided much
like Emma Eckstein's knows that they
were going to cauterize the foreskin off
rather than cutting it like they
normally wouldn't it did not go well and
essentially they burned the poor little
kids penis off yeah damn more or less so
you know yeah I can't make a mistake
like that doesn't mean I mean I know
babies are small and baby penises are
small but still come on man like if
you're gonna do that dude right yeah so
a lawsuit well yeah well here's the
thing I don't even I don't even know if
there was but um understandably the
other brother the other twin brother
they were like yeah let's not do that to
that other kid so the baby boy's parents
were understandably concerned because
they said well you know what's what's he
gonna do now that I mean they they
couldn't do like phalloplasty and stuff
back then I don't think they were you
know they the surgery was probably in
its infancy so it's like they're like
what he's not gonna be able to have
children he's not gonna be able to have
like normal sexual relationship turned a
boy to a girl yeah so they they didn't
know what to do so they took him to dr.
John money because like I said dr. money
was you know famous for working with
intersex patients and they said you know
they burned off his penis it's like what
should we do now at the time dr. money
was one of the leading proponents of the
theory that gender or sex or gender was
largely due to nurture it was largely
socially constructed now while I don't
know see while it's understandable why
it's because some things about gender
presentation and things like that are
socially constructed I mean obviously
the wind
dressing is the window dress alike back
in it allergy right but you know back in
the old days pink and blue now now it's
a girl and boy color but you know back
in the old days it was opposite you know
back in the old days dudes or makeup and
high heels and wigs and no one thought
that was girly or anything like oh man
in the 17 yeah that was manly back that
happen
yeah so things like that sure socially
constructed
however the problem here was one I mean
this boy was not born with ambiguous
genitalia he was not born with any
chromosomal aberration he was
biologically he is biologically male he
was born you know a heterosexual
evidently a heterosexual normal with
normal male genitalia but dr. John money
became convinced he's like well if now
he thought if you got them in the window
before they turned two years old and
raised them as a particular gender then
they would identify with that gender so
he suggested to this boy's parents that
we will rate will change his name to
Brenda and we will raise him as a girl
and also dr. John money I think it must
be said was kind of like all excited
because the kid had a twin brother who
was still intact because they hadn't
operated on him so he said it's a
brother was a perfect control they
wanted to see how things would turn out
so like I said they changed the kid's
name to Brenda started putting him
addresses started raising him as a girl
and stuff like that right Glen or Glenda
yeah he was just a transvestite to wear
women's clothing he was straight so I
didn't work out yeah well as much as
janmani liked to say in and there's a
lot of he-said she-said going on here
right there's a really good book by
what's-his-name Jon Cola Pinto I think
is the guy's name he wrote a book called
as nature nature made him and I read it
a few years ago and it's really good and
that was kind of written from you know
the kids perspective now dr. Jon money
he kind of thought at first the
experiment was a success
like all of his paperwork at the time
and stuff was like you know yeah he's
acting like a girl and he's accepting
you know he's accepting his gender
identity and stuff like that however
they're not sure if he thought that
because you know he wanted the
experiment to succeed and he was just
seeing what he wanted to see or if the
kid's parents were lying to him about
how successful it was going cuz I mean
he didn't see the kid every day he only
saw him like every now and then what
ended up happening was when he started
to get a little bit older now keep in
mind that he did not know that he had
been born as a boy right he said you
know through his entire youth probably
when he started being like eight or nine
years old he started being really
uncomfortable with being a girl he
didn't want to do girl things he didn't
you know he was given dolls he didn't
want them he was made to wear frilly
dresses he wouldn't wear them and he
began to get bullied at school and you
know he was real withdrawn and stuff
like that just because and he didn't
really understand why because like I
said he wasn't told that he was born as
a boy he was just like why am i why do I
have to wear this and why do I don't
want to play with that I want to go
climb trees and shoot stuff and
everything a long story short genders
biological it's now so largely
biological yeah so um not a social
contract they want to say that you know
and some social studies courses in
universities today but humans are
animals animals are controlled by
biology in many aspects they are and I'm
not saying and like I said you know I
want to say it's a lot more nuanced than
that because you know biology and you
know nature and nurture kind of interact
with each other because the human brain
is kind of plastic and the environment
affects it and your brain and you know
changes the environment in turn so it's
kind of like a feedback loop type of
thing but in general if the kid was born
a boy and he knew he was of like he knew
it wasn't right right that he was being
treated and but he didn't know why so he
had like all kind of identity
now there are only two genders there are
male and female and then there's a third
section that is kind of a mixture of two
different things like sense that
ambiguous but in general if you're born
male or you're born female you're about
him by your biology dictates your your
behavior well I mean humans humans are
not some kind of special spiritual I'm
not saying there's there's where animals
were machines like the other animals but
I mean there's a large spectrum of
behaviors on that I mean obviously some
girls are more boyish than other ones
and some boys are more family than other
ones and things like that they're male
or female right there's a big spectrum
so like I said they finally told the kid
they are what they are though yeah and
like I said this kid knew something was
about it but he didn't know why so
finally they told the kid when he was
about 12 or right before he went through
puberty that he had been born a boy and
he said that it was a great relief no
because he sounded all made sense yeah
he's like oh well that's why you know
what I mean because I think the reason
they told him was because he flipped out
when they were going to take him because
you know he hadn't had a penis and he
hadn't had a vagina for his entire child
he he peed through a hole in his abdomen
Sam because they hadn't you know they
hadn't really had he didn't know
something's wrong no like he just
thought something well something went
wrong you know he was a kid this you
know he happened when he was a baby so
you know remember so you know when he
was getting a little older they
suggested that he go have you know a
budget partial rudimentary vagina
constructed and he did not want to do
that right like he specifically I'm
going to kill myself if you take me back
there right so you know that was when
they told me he was a boy now when he
was 15 he just he went back to living as
a male now there have been some
allegations that I don't know how true
this is that I mean they they said him
and his brother said that when they were
still kids that doctor money would kind
of put them into kind of sexual
situations where where Bruce was Bruce
slash Brenda was made to play the role
of the bottom and then like the brother
would kind of thrust
like to just kind of show him like what
how it was supposed to go I guess yeah
like I said I don't I don't know if
that's true or not there have been
allegations that the kids had false
memory system or syndrome or coached or
something like that but um the the
brothers did say that the doctor made
them do that types of things to get
their sexual roles right I guess so he
started he too actually took the name
David even though he'd been born with
the name Bruce but he took the name
David later on and I started living as a
male now eventually he did get I believe
he did get like a phalloplasty like he
had a fake penis constructed and he
actually did go on to marry later on
though I don't believe I don't think he
was ever fertile like he could never
because they took his testicles off so
he could never have children but he did
marry and he adopted his wife's three
children however it really did not end
in a happy in a happy way now he had
been given estrogen prior to like I said
when he was a kid but they stopped they
gave him testosterone later and you know
so he started living as a boy and and he
seemed much happier after that but he
never really recovered gore's 'no and
and honestly you know his his brother
actually died his twin brother died of a
drug overdose right and a couple years
after that his wife asked for a
separation and now before he died he did
tell his story to kind of encourage
other psychiatrist not to do that to a
kid anymore and you know from that from
that initial story that he gave there
was a book written like I said called as
nature made him which is really good if
you want to read it so after his wife
left
he basically drove to her parking lot
and blew his head off with a shotgun so
and he was yeah he was only in his 30s
yeah that's a big program on it you know
they said it's not only just hormones
and you know genitalia it's in your
cells too you can just you know pull the
cell out of a person and
see if they're male or they're female
and sometimes a male might have female
sales and vice versa with his weird yeah
it's weird and like I said you know I'm
willing to the problem I had with this
was that what should have been done like
I said the kid was not born with any
kind of chromosomal aberration right he
was not born he was not an intersex
child he was not transgender he was not
any of those things and the fact that
they took away his consent I mean to do
that I mean it was bad enough that they
burned his penis off yeah okay
you know I know [ __ ] happens and it's
terrible and stuff like that but then to
compound that error yeah right
by changing his sex but yeah the kid
can't use a baby
he couldn't consent and for and for the
record I don't I don't really agree with
circumcision anyway well he thought they
thought they could change his sex I
didn't think that sex is a big deal yes
we'll just turn him into it yeah I guess
they thought doesn't really work that
way no it doesn't but I mean I guess
they didn't know that now they do
because of that yeah but um you know
probably I mean the best-case scenario
well best-case scenario that wouldn't
burn the kid's penis off but yeah and
the sad thing too was that I forgot to
mention that you know you know they
burned the one kid's penis out now the
twin brother had the same condition he
had by Moses too but it went away on its
own
so they wouldn't have even had to do
anything so you know that would have
been the ideal situation now had that
happened anyway the ideal situation
probably would have been to just leave
the kid as he was and then see what
happened later on you know and if the
kid grew up it was obviously a boy then
you could go from there you could be
like well we'll make him a penis and you
know he still wouldn't be able to have
children and stuff like that but you
know he wouldn't have had identity
crisis his whole life poor head but you
know so yeah he ended up killing himself
and I'm sorry that was kind of like the
note we had and
because I was kind of about God man
everything we should have ended with the
Freud one because at least that was kind
of funny well except for that the show
food that woman
yeah really did well you know it was
kind of an interesting topic and like I
said oh I got it right down we should
probably do a show on Carl Jung now that
you mention it cuz that that would be a
good topic to do but anyway so alright
so we're done talking I guess as always
thank you to project Entertainment
Network for hosting the audio version of
our show and they have a patreon at
patreon.com slash project and net if you
want to go give them a buck or two not
just done just support our podcast also
a bunch of other good ones that are on
there and also we have some t-shirts at
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock there's five
different designs and you can pick
whatever one you want and they're all
pretty cool and I think that's pretty
Owen also I mentioned at the beginning
but if you're into paranormal stuff
poltergeist stuff specifically then go
and pick up a copy of my newest book the
unseen hand a new exploration of
poltergeist phenomena in print ebook or
audiobook and if you like it please
leave me a review on Amazon because it
really does help out yeah and I guess
that's pretty much it for this week
roll music roll music bye
[Music]
science
[Music]
you
[Music]